اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ملفات الخامسه من
العربيه والبدايه كالمعتاد بابرز عناوينها
استراتيجيه المانيه جديده للامن القوميه
تعتبر روسيا اكبر تهديد جدي للنظام الدولي
واوروبا
الامم المتحده تؤكد نزوحها اكثر من مليوني
سوداني في الداخل والخارج منذ بدء الصراع
قبل شهرين
وقبيل احتفاله بعامه السابع والسبعين
ومن ملفات الخامسه اسدال الستار على قضيه
الفتاه المصريه نيره اشرف بتنفيذ حكم
الاعدام علاقاتها اليوم
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ملفات الخامسه من
العربيه كشف المستشار الالماني عن
استراتيجيه جديده للامن القومي تركز على
امن الطاقه والصين ووصف استراتيجيه الامن
القومي الالماني روسيا بانها اكبر تهديد
جدي للنظام الدولي واوروبا كما نصت على ان
روسيا تهدد الديمقراطيه في اوروبا ويجب
التصديلها وشددت الاستراتيجيه الالمانيه
الجديده على ضروره الالتزام بمسار النيتو
وتخصيص اثنين بالمئه من الناتج للانفاق
الدفاعي استراتيجيه الامن القومي الالماني
طالبت ايضا بانشاء مركز فيدرالي لمواجهه
الهجمات الخارجيه بينما حذرت وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه من ان الامن في القرن
الحادي والعشرين يعني الا تجسس الصين الا
تتجسس الصين على الهواتف
وينضم الينا من مدينه خرسون السفير
شوماكوبا الدبلوماسيه السابق ومستشاره
حاكم خرسون سابقا مرحبا بك ومن موسكو ايضا
ينضم الينا دبلوماسي السابق والمحلل
السياسي
مرحبا بك السيد ماتازوف هناك سؤال الان
بات واضحا الجميع وخاصه امريكا والغرب وفي
مقدمته المانيا اليوم يقولون انكم العدو
الاكبر للعالم كيف ستتعاملون مع هذا
التوصيف وتداعياته
تعبان عدو الاكبر اليوم للغرب لولايات
المتحده الامريكيه للروسيا وليست هذا بسبب
موقف الروسي من اهداف اوكرانيا لان قوات
مسلح الروسيه وصلوا الى اراضي في اوكرانيا
نتيجه
السياسه الغربيه سياسه
امريكيه
وتلك الادوات الامريكيه في اوروبا بما
فيها موقف الماني موقف الماني تعاني اليوم
مشاكل ضخمه اقتصاديه لكل شيء بسبب
سياسه امريكيه ليست سياسه الروسيه ولذلك
عندما نحن نتحدث ان تدهور
وتدهور علاقات بين المانيا وروسيا هذه
التظاهر ناتج من
تلك العمليه ارهابيه
نظمت والراعيه ولايات المتحده مثل تفجير
لانابيب غاز نوت ستريم واحد نوت ستريم
اثنين وكذلك
تزويد الجيش شكريني بسلاح لان كانت لديهم
خيار
هل السياسي مشكله
الاحترام امن القومي الروسي يا
تراجع ويفرض هيمنه وسيطره على روسيا على
منطقه كولا هذا طريقك في العالم
منعت امريكا ان ياخذ موقف سليم
والمفكر
ومدروس
ومعقل في ما يتعلق
بانتشار حلف الشمال
رفضوا مفاوضات في ديسمبر
ورفضت المانيا والدول
الدول الاوروبيه
لنستمع الى راي السيد شوماكو سيد شوماكوب
ما نفهمه من كلام السيد ان هناك تزييف
للواقع وان هناك صوره نمطيه يحاول الغرب
ومعهم اوكرانيا بالطبع تصديرها عن روسيا
وهي صوره غير صحيحه وكانه يقول انكم
تكذبون وتخدعون
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
وتحيه من خيرسون بصراحه هنا في خرسانه نحن
نشاهد عواقب عواقب من سياسه وتنفيذ سياسه
مطهوره سيد بوتين نحن نشاهد بان روسيا هي
مستعده اتخاذ تضمير في هذا حرب هنا في
اوكرانيا هؤلاء المانيا اكيده نوشروا
يعني مين بدايه حرب علمنا مواصر وخاصه
اوكرانيا ودولانيه
رهينه في اياد
روسيا ابتازت تعليمنا معاصره
بازمه غذائيه عندما روسيا عركله ومنعتر
صادرات الحبوب من اوكرانيا بصراحه
مليون شخص كمان روسيا
الان باستخدام اسلحه نوويه
هو الذي كان معرض
للخاطفه عن امنيه القوميه وفقا لوجهه
النظر الروسيه
بصراحه روسيا استخدمت قضيه الناتو
الانذاريه على الهجوم على اوكرانيا عند
تذاكروا منذ تقريبا سنه ونصف افادا امين
اوكرانيا ممكن سوف تدخل الى فيناتو بعض
عشره سنوات يعني ابواب مفتوحه لكل العالم
لكل الدول ولكن ليست لاوكرانيا الانضمام
الى ناطره نحن شاهدنا بان الناتو كانت
بصراحه في غيبوبه قبل روسيا على اوكرانيا
هدف اندونيسي هل عدم خروج اوكرانيا من
منطقه نفوز روسيه والان بسبب الحمض العاجز
الى روسيا
اللي هي لا تستطيع احتلال كل اوكرانيا هي
لا تستطيع ان تغير نظام في اوكرانيا كما
ارادت في بدايه حرب وبهذا سابق روسيا
تمتاز علي من المعاصر وتهدد باستخدام
اسلحه نوويه وخاصه
فقط الامن القومي الاوروبيه او الاوكراني
ولكنكم ربما تهددون ان العالم بالتهديد
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه كيف تربون على
هذه الاتهامات
طبعا
مبررات
وتفاصيل حول اسباب دخول القوات الروسيه
الى ارض اوكرانيه
لكل طرف هناك اسباب ولكن هذا ما يذكرنا
انا احد اسباب هي القمح هذا لانه اذكر
لاديمير ان كل القمح وكل الحقول الزراعيه
في اوكرانيا التابعه ليست حتى مشكله ليس
حكم
ان كل
الاجراكودنجكي ومحصول من قمح في هذا
المنطقه هي ملك الشركات الامريكيه ولذلك
يجري حديث ليست لاستيراد القمح اما قمح
تابع
ملكيته لامريكا لا يرد سيد على هذه النقطه
لانها حساسه انتم تتبعون الهيمنه
الامريكيه وفقا لهذا الوصف وليس لكم سياده
حتى على الارض فيما يتعلق بمساله القمح
كيف تردون على ذلك
مهمه جدا من الممكن الان اوكرانيا
ولكن مين طرد اوكرانيا
بالنسبه لروسيا على هجمت غادره بعد
اوكرانيا ودمرت اقتصاد اوكرانيا حول حقوق
الاوكرانيه بالمناسبه لتذاكر يعني في
الاوكرانيا تعامل في مجال الزراعه عدد
الداخل من الشركات وكمان شركه السعوديه
التي في محفظتها اكثر من 200 الف هكتار
حبوب من الاراضي من تربه صراعيه في
اوكرانيا كما في وسط اوكرانيا وكمان في
غارب اوكرانيا وهذه الشركه السعوديه هي
تعمل بنجاح يعني انا كمان بالمناسبه وايضا
المزارعين والمزارع بهذا السبب في
اوكرانيا كبيره من الشركات وليس فقط
امريكيه وللاسفه شديد الرو سي هي تعرق
للصادرات حبوب من اوكرانيا ليس فقط حبوب
ولكن منتجات الزراعيه
ضيق سيده كيف ترد على هذه الاتهامات ويقول
ليس هناك سيطره امريكيه كما تقول ولكن
هناك تنوع والدليل ان هناك بعض الشركات
العربيه ومنها الشركه السعوديه التي اشار
اليها ويقول فيما معناه ان ربما ما فعلت
روسيا هو من راما باوكرانيا في احضان
الغرب وامريكا
روسيا امتلاكا على مسالح الدول الاخرى دول
غير اوكرانيا غير روسيا
وافقت على فتح الابواب لتصدير قمح
اوكرانيا الى خارج الى وين واصلت تلك
القمع الى الدول الاسيويه فاك الصلاه في
المئه من القمح ترسل الى دول اسيويه اما
تسعه وسبعه وتسعين في المئه كله
ارسلوا الى دول اوروبيه وروسيا فتحت ابواب
للصفقه القمح خلال سنه كامله تقريبا
يتحدثون عن هذا الصفقه ويستمر ملايين طن
من هذه النقطه لكنك لم ترد على ما قاله لك
بشان تهديد العالم باستخدام السلاح النووي
لم ترد على هذه النقطه سيد متى سوف اذا
سمحت سريعا
استعمال
القنبله النوويه مستحيله هذا يكفي اليوم
الاسلحه عاديه والان واضح تماما ان كل
التهديدات لروسيا بدبابات المانيا الى فرض
واحد الى اثنين
او عبرام كل هذا الروايه انتهت نعم اذا
وضحت الفكره شكرا لكم على هذا النقاش من
خرسون السيد فلود دبلوماسيه السابق
ومستشار حاكم خرسون شكرا لك
في تطور اللافت ايضا اعلن رئيس
البيلاروسيه الكسني ان بلاده بدات تتسلم
اسلحه ثانويه تكتيكيه من روسيا وقال
لكوشينكو في تصريحات الاعلام الروسي ان
روسيا لم تسع او لم تسعى الى وضع صواريخها
النوويه في بيلاروسيا بل العكس مشيرا الى
ان مينيسك هي التي طلبت ذلك اولا وكانت
روسيا وبيلاروسيا اتفقت على نشر صواريخ
الكسندر ام ومقاتلات سيخوي قادره على حمل
القنابل النوويه التكتيكيه
لطالما كنا هدفا لقد ارادوا تمزيقنا الى
اجزاء منذ عام 2020 لكن لم يكن احد في
حاله حرب ضد دوله لديها اسلحه نوويه
لدينا صواريخ وقنابل تلقيناها من روسيا
وكلاهما اقوى بثلاث مرات من تلك التي
اسقطتها الولايات المتحده في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
سينتشر لدينا الكثير من مرافق تخزين
الاسلحه النوويه ولدينا بالفعل الكثير
منها وسوف نستعيد المزيد ولن نحتفظ بها
كلها في مكان واحد
مايدانيا اعلنت الاداره العسكريه في
اوديستا مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه ثلاثه
عشر اخرين في قصف صاروخي روسي على ميناء
اوديسا جنوب اوكرانيا وذكرت في بيان لها
ان القتل ثلاثه موظفون في مستودع تجاري
اصيب بصاروخ كروز روسيه
واضافت الاداره العسكريه لاوردسا ان
الهجوم دمر مستودعات مساحتها الف متر مربع
وسبب حريقا على مساحه 400 متر مربع
وهذه اتهمت الاداره المحليه المواليه
لروسيا القوات الاوكرانيه بقصف مناطق
سكنيه ما ادى الى اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص وقالت
في بيان لها ان اوكرانيا لم تتوقف عن قصف
المدينه رغم استمرار عمليات الاجلاء بعد
تدمير سد النبغه واشارت الى ان
7200 من الاشخاص تم اجلاؤهم من المناطق
التي غمرتها الفيضانات
شدد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
ديميتريديف على ضروره ان تمتد المنطقه
العازله المستقبليه المحتمله التي تحدث
عنها الرئيس بوتين لتكون على طول حدود
لفيف على الحدود البولنديه في اشاره لنزع
سلاح اوكرانيا بالكامل من جهه اخرى قال
مدريديف ان تواطؤ الغرب الذي وصفه بالمؤكد
في استهداف خطى نرد او خطيه يرفعوا جميع
القيود حتى الاخلاقيه لضرب خطوط الاتصالات
لاعداء روسيا في اعماق المحيط كما جاء في
بيانه
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان اوكرانيا
حاولت شن هجمات على جنوب دونسك خلال 24
ساعه الماضيه حيث اصدرت الوزاره بيانا
يقول فيه ان هناك استهداف لمستودعات
للاسلحه الاوكرانيه خلال الهجمات الليليه
كما اكدت بان قوات الاوكرانيه عانت من
خسائر فادحه برجالها ومعداتها
هذا واعتبر مؤسس فاجنري بدين بروجين طلبه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من المتطوعين بتوقيع
عقود بانه عار واقترح حلا وسطا يحصل فيه
المتطوعون على ضمانات اجتماعيه ووثائق
كمشاركين في الاعمال القتاليه
اوضاع الانسانيه صعبه يعاني منها سكان
المناطق التي اجتاحها او اجتاحتها السيول
في خرسون نتيجه تفجير سد ومحطه
مواطنون قادتهم الظروف الى الاقامه في غرف
المرضى بالمستشفيات رغم انهم ليسوا بمرضى
واخرون اتخذوا من المدارس ودور الثقافه
ملدا لهم وجميعهم لا يدري متى وكيف ستنتهي
الكارثه المشهد رصده موفد العربيه الى
خرسون الزميل حذيفه عادل
نحن هنا في مستشفى خرسون حيث المعاناه
اكبر عند اصحاب الامراض المزمنه وكبار
السن الذين فتح مستشفى خرسون ابوابه
لاستقبال النازحين منهم ومن تم اجلائهم من
مناطق الفيضان ممن يحتاجون الرعايه الصحيه
وحتى اولئك الذين لا يحتاجون اليها ولكنهم
لا يجدون مسكنا فقد تم اسكانهم بشكل مؤقت
في عنابر المستشفى حتى تجد السلطات حللا
لاوضاعهم
في الوقت الحالي في القطاع يوجد 51 شخصا
منهم من يحتاج الى رعايه الصحيه هنا يوجد
من تم تنويمهم وفي الطوابق الاعلى يوجد
اشخاص لا يحتاجون الى الرعايه تم تسكينهم
ولكن على الرغم من ذلك اذا كانت لديهم اي
شكوى كارتفاع الضغط او الصداع نقدم لهم
المساعده تحدثنا الى بعض المواطنين
المقيمين في المستشفى كالجده الله التي
فقد زوجها منذ اعوام وتعيش وحيده غبرت
المياه منزلها بالكامل واتلفت الاثاث
وجميع ممتلكاتها ولا تدري ما حل بالمنزل
بعد ان تم اجلائها
في الصباح استيقظنا على سياح رجل كان يصرخ
اخرج سنساعدكم لان المياه اتيه منك خفقه
وستغرقون
بدات عمليه الاجلاء وانا معاق لذلك قررت
الانتظار لم اكن اعتقد ان المياه يمكنها
الوصول الى هذا الارتفاع ولكن اضطررت الى
الاتصال بجارتي التي طلبت الدفاع المدني
والذين اتوا واخرجوني بصعوبه
الفيضان اغرق مساحات واسعه حيث لا تزال 46
بلده مغموره بالمئه معظمها في الضفه
اليمنى حيث سيطره الاوكرانيين والبقيه في
مناطق سيطره الروس الا ان المعاناه واحده
فقد الناس حياتهم وممتلكاتهم واصبحوا
نازحين يعيشون على الاعانات الانسانيه
تداعيات الكارثه البيئيه لا يمكن التنبؤ
بها ومصير الاف البيوت وممتلكات الناس ما
زال مجهولا وتحذر السلطات من دخول مناطق
الفيضان حتى بعد انحسار المياه خوفا من
الالغام التي غطاها الطنيو واصبح من الصعب
الكشف عنها ولا احد يتحدث عن عوده قريبه
لمن اجبرهم الفيضان على النزوح ضيف عادل
العربيه من مدينه خرسون
ونبقى معكم في سياق الخامسه من العربيه
ولدينا
يعتبر محاكمته محاوله لسرقه الانتخابات
المقبله ويتهم بايدن بالفساد ويقول محاكمه
استغلال شرير للسلطه
عهد السعوديه على غداء عمل يناقش خلاله
الجانبان قضايا اقليميه وقضايا دوليه في
طليعتها الحرب في اوكرانيا والتداعياتها
على بقيه العالم كما سيشارك ولي العهد
بحسب الرئاسه الفرنسيه في القمه الماليه
العالميه والهدف منها الجمع بين التمويل
الخاص والتمويل العام وهو ما تحتاج اليه
الارض وشعوبها من اجل مكافحه الفقر وقياده
تحول المناخي والتنوع البيولوجي بحسب قصر
والى التطورات السودان اتهمت قوات الدعم
السريع في السودان الجيش بالسعي لاشعال
حرب قبليه في اقليم دارفور والزجي بمكونات
الاقليم في مواجهات ذات طابع قبلي وقال
الدعم السريع في بيان له ان الجيش
السوداني حول الحرب من سياسيه الى قبليه
بين مكونات الاقليم داعيا مواطني اقليم
دارفور بعدم الاستجابه لمخططات الجيش
السوداني حسب ما جاء في بيان الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
شهران مره على الصراع المسلح في السودان
وفي اخر ارقام الضحايا كشفت نقابه اطباء
السودان ان عدد القتلى المدنيين منذ بدايه
الصراع ارتفع الى نحو 958 شخصا واضافت ان
جميع مستشفيات الجنينه بدرفور خارج الخدمه
وان الوضع كارثي جاء هذا في وقت حضرت فيه
العديد من المنظمات الانسانيه من ان
استمرار الصراع في السودان يمكن ان يتحول
الى حرب اهليه وسعه النطاق مع تزايد عدد
المفقودين وايضا القتلى وتراجع مستوى
الخدمات الصحيه
هدد لتحضر الاوروبي بمحاسبه طرفي النزاع
في السودان بسبب استمرار المعارك وخرق هدى
لوقف اطلاق النار واضاف للاتحاد الاوروبي
ان العقوبات ستفرض على طرفي النزاع في
السودان بشان انتهاك القانون الانساني
الدولي وعرقله عمل الفرق الامميه في ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه الى المناطق المتضرره
بسبب المعارك واجباري اكثر من مليوني شخص
على النزوح وفقا لتقارير امميه
اعلنت المفاوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين ان نحو 110 ملايين شخص
اضطروا للفرار من ديارهم بسبب الصراع او
الاضطهاد او انتهاكات حقوقهم الانسانيه
اقل المفاوض السامي للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين في لبو جراندي ان الصراعها في
السودان الذي تسبب في نزوح قرابه مليوني
شخص ليس سوى احدث حلقه في قائمه طويله من
الازمات التي ادت الى هذا العدد القياسي
هذا وتتواصل عمليات النزوح لسكان مدينه
نيالا في جنوب دارفور غرب السودان في ظل
استمرار المعارك العنيفه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع حيث اختار البعض منهم التوجه
الى مدينه الضعين في شرق دارفور لانها
تتمتع بهدوء نسبي
هي مشاهد تلخص حجم المعاناه التي يعيشها
العشرات من سكان مدينه نيالا جنوب دارفور
شاحنات وسياره اجره في كل مكان
وحقائب تنتظر اصحابها بانتظار الانتقال
الى وجهات قريبه او بعيده اي وجهات فالوضع
هنا لم يعد يطاق انا طبعا استاذ محمد صالح
واحد من سكان المنطقه الذين اختاروا
التوجه الى مدينه الضعين في شرق دارفور
خشيه تعرض عائلته للموت بسبب القصف
المتواصل واملا في الحصول على عمل فللحياه
كلفه لم تعد متوفره في منطقته
اذا لقينا البلد هناك ما افضل كمان بدنا
نشوف لنا اتجاه ثاني جنيهه معدوده في اليد
لا تكفي فالبعض من سكان المنطقه اشتكوا
عدم قدرتهم على توفير نفقات النزوح الى
خارج المدينه بعد ان قفزت اسعار التذاكر
من 4000 جنيه سوداني الى ثلاثين الفا وفقا
للسائق جبريل عيسى
وصلنا
لاسباب الحرب
[موسيقى]
الاشتباكات التي تدخل يومها الستين خلفت
وراءها عشرات القتلى ومئات الجرحى ووضعا
اجتماعيا كارثيا بيوت ددمت متاجر اغلقت
وصيدليات بقيت عاجزه عن توفير الادويه
احنا
زادنا الان يعني غلبنا الشغل فيه وحتى لنا
المركبات حتى التواهين يعني الان ما قدروا
يشتغلوها ومع التوصل الاشتباكات وسط
الامال بتوقفها باتجل ما يتمناه المرء في
نيالا هو مكان ياويه ويقيه ويلات الحرب
فلا امان ممكن اكثر من ذلك
[موسيقى]
الجنائيه للمره الثانيه الاحتفاضه بوثائق
سريه في منزله في فلوريدا في الوقت الذي
يخطط فيه لعودته الى البيت الابيض ليصبح
بذلك اول رئيس سابق في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده يواجه اتهامات جنائيه محاكمه
ترامب قد تمتد طويلا ولكن ماذا لو فاز
بالرئاسه التوقعات هنا تختلف البعض يرى
انه من غير المرجح ان تستمر المحاكمه
لاسيما وانهم يعتقدون ان وزاره العدل
تعتبر جزءا من السلطه التنفيذيه فيما
الرؤساءهم اعلى سلطات انفاذ القوانين
الفيدراليه في البلاد وبالتالي يسعى
المدعون الفيدراليون دائما لارضاء الرؤساء
في حين يرى اخرون انه في حال الحكم بادانه
ترامب بعد فوزه بالانتخابات فليس امامه
الا ان يبقى في السجن او يدفع غرامه ماليه
للحصول على حكم بوقف التنفيذ وحينها سيصبح
رئيس امريكي يتعرضوه للادانه من ناحيتها
ترى مجله الامريكيه عدم وجود اجابه واضحه
حتى اللحظه لما سيحدث حاله ادانه قبل او
بعد فوزه بالانتخابات ولا يعرف احد مصير
القضايا المرفوعه ضده لكن من المؤكد هو ان
ترامب رغم المحاكمه يتقدم على منافسه
الجمهوريين في سباق الرئاسي باشواط وفقا
للارقام
[تصفيق]
هذا اضطهاد سياسي مثل ما يحدث بشكل صريح
من امه فاشيه او شيوعيه وسوف يسجل هذا
اليوم باعتباره عارا وسيظل جو بايدن في
الذاكره الى الابد باعتباره الرئيس الاكثر
فسادا في تاريخ بلدنا والاهم من ذلك
الرئيس الذي حاول مع عصابه البلطجيه
المقربه وغير الاسوياء والمركسيين تدمير
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
كم يمكن ان تستغرق تلك المحاكمه يرى بعض
الخبراء ان الامر قد يستغرق عاما او اكثر
قبل اصدار الحكم اذ ان هناك من يتوقع ان
يبدا المدعون الفيدراليون كخطوه اولى في
تسليم الادله لمحامي ترامب والتي تشمل
سنوات من المراسلات التي حصلت بين محاميه
واداره المحفوظات والسجلات والمدعين
العامين حول تسليم الوثائق ثم لاحقا يتوقع
ان يقدم فريق الدفاع عن الرئيس السابق
ترامب طلبا لرفض القضيه لعده اسباب بما في
ذلك ادعائه رفع السريع عن الوثائق قبل
عقدها معه عند مغادره البيت الابيض كذلك
من المحتمل ايضا ان يطالب البعض بضروره
اسقاط القضيه لما يعتبروه سوء سلوك وتحذير
من قبل المدعين ومخالفه لمبدا قانوني يسمح
للاشخاص بالحفاظ على سريه الاتصالات مع
محاميهم الذي نفى ارتك اب اي مخالفات ووصف
القضيه بمطارده الساحرات له الحق في
مواجهه المحكمه في غضون 100 يوم لكن هذا
نادرا ما يحدث في مثل تلك القضايا المعقده
وينضم الينا من واشنطن دكتور وليد فارس
الخبير في شؤون السياسه الامريكيه مرحبا
بك دكتور ربما ينطبق على هذه القضيه
الجميع حائرون لا احد يعرف ما هو الصواب
وما هو الخطا فيما يحدث على الارض بالنسبه
لبدء المحاكمه هل هي خطوه امام مسلسل طويل
ام ان الامر يمكن ان يحسم سريعا
من اطول المسلسلات انها انه مسلسل الادغال
القانونيه والعدليه وقد قيل يعني طبعا
ورددتم ذلك انه هذه لاول مره يحاكم رئيس
او قد يصبر قرار ولكن هذه لاول مره كل شيء
يعني هذا الصراع المستمر منذ ان انتخب
الرئيس ترامبو حتى منذ الحمله حتى الان ست
سنوات لم نرى مثيرا لها في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الحديث والانقسام هو
انقسام عمودي كبير سياسي نحن لا ننسى ان
الرئيس ترامب كان رئيسا وكان له اداره وهم
يعلمون باوضاع الوزارات الداخليه يعني لن
تمر هذه الاشهر الاتيه بشكل طبيعي وكان من
يحاكم هو سي او او مدير عام لشركه معينه
انها شبه حرب سياسيه اهليه بين جهازين
لهما المعلومات الكافيه انا لا اريد ان
اضع دراماتيكيه ولكن هذا ما نقراه اذن لا
ارى ان تكون قصيره بل ستكون طويله جدا طيب
دكتور وليد المتابع للتاريخ الامريكي كان
نموذج للديمقراطيه ربما يصدم مما يسمعه
هذه الايام في الاعلام الامريكي من فكره
الاتهامات التي يقدمها انصاره بان هناك
شبهه سياسيه في هذه القضايا وان ليس هناك
استقلال للسلطات القضائيه وانها تمت تصفيه
حسابات سياسيه وان هناك دوله عميقه هذه
التعبيرات لم يعتاد عليها المتابع للشان
الامريكي وكاننا نتحدث عن دوله ربما من
عالم اخر
لم يعتاد عليها من لم يعش معنا في امريكا
منذ ثلاث اربع سنوات لكل هذه العبارات
استعملت ولكن حتى الذي لم يكن يعني يتفاعل
مع ما يجري الان وصلت الى قمه العالم كله
يتاثر نحن نعرف تماما اذا خسرت ترامب
طياره ومشروعه العالمي سوف يتاثر واذا كسب
الاخرون نفس الشيء ولا ننسى ان كل اداره
بنهايه المطاف ربما اقولها لاول مره لها
دوله ما هي الدوله العميقه رؤساء الاجهزه
الذين يهتمون باستمرار هذه الدوله اذا
حدثت كارثه ولكن المشكله الان انه ليس
هنالك من كارثه لا طبيعيه ولا امن قومي
ولكن هنالك من كارثه قانونيه كيف يمكن
محاكمه رئيس سابق وكيف يمكن تطبيق المبادئ
العدليه الامريكيه لقد تفضلتم وتكلمتم عن
اصول المحاكمات يعني ما بامكان فريق
الدفاع ان يقوم به المساله ليست سهله لن
تهضم بسهوله خاصه عليها
يعني كما حدث يقال سابقا ليس هناك سابقا
ليس هنالك السابقه هنالك بعض المقارنات
ربما
او قبل الحرب الحرب الاهليه الامريكيه
ولكن لا يمكن مقارناتها لانه ليس هنالك
حرب ميدانيه على الارض ولكن حرب سياسيه
قويه جدا واختم هذا النقطه بالقول انه
المعركه الحقيقيه للترامب وقد يبدو ذلك
عجيبا ليست مع العدل لانه فريق المحامين
سيحاول الاستطاله ولكن مع خصمه في فلوريدا
وهو الخصم الحقيقي يعني كل ما يجي ان اثر
على ترامب سيؤثر على قدرته ان ينتصر ويحصل
ضد غريمه السياسي الداخلي في الحزب
الجمهوري روند
نعم هل ما يحدث لصالح ديسانس بالفعل ام ان
القاعده الشعبيه الجمهوريه تتعاطف اكثر
واكثر مع ترامب في ظل هذه الظروف لاننا
شاهدنا ان ديسنت يدافع عنه ماك بانسي
يدافع عنه
سيدتي يدافعون عنهم ولكن اذا قراتم الخطاب
يدافعون وهم غير مقتنعين ويقولون اخطاء
ويقولون لو كنا مكانه لكان الامر نفس
الشيء ولكن بنفس الوقت يمررون اخبار انه
هو اتى بهذه المشاكل لذاته يعني كان
بامكانه ترامب ان لا يدخل هذا المعترك
معترك الوثائق السريه يعني اخر حاجه في
الادارات بامكانه ان يوجه الرئيس ان لا
يستعمل هذه الاوراق او لا يتكلم عنها فيها
شيء من الصحه انه احيانا الرئيس ترامب
يعني يقول امور دون ان تكون له نيه
لاجرميه ولا التصرف بهذه الوثائق وهذا
باعتقاد الفريق الدفاع سوف يركز في
المحاكمه عندما تبدا عمليا انه كل جرم يجب
ان يكون هنالك فيه نيه جرميه طيب دكتور
وليد هو
يقول هذه الوثائق او محاموه يقولون ان هذه
الوثائق تم رفع
ادانه هذه معلومه بسيطه يمكن التاكد منها
اذا كانت تم رفع السريع عنها لماذا كل هذه
الضجه اذا
هذه الضجه لانه ليست هنالك اليه واضحه
لمعرفه كيف يمكن لرئيس سابق عندما كان
رئيسا في الساعات الاخيره ان يرفع السريه
بالمبدا الدستوريه نعم الرئيس حتى اخر
دقيقه بامكانه ولكن هنالك اليه معينه
بتقديري هذه النقطه سوف يتم الاشتباك
حولها في المحاكم ومن الممكن ان تذهب الى
المحكمه العليا انا مساله دستوريه عميقه
وهذا ماذا يعني وقت طويل نعم دكتور وليد
فارس الخبير في الشؤون السياسيه الامريكيه
نستفيد من حضرتك دائما دكتور تحياتي
اعلنت الامم المتحده انها بدات عمليه
انقاذ ناقله صافر ومنع كارثه بيئيه كبيره
قد تتسبب في تسريب النفطي قبل سواحل اليمن
مشيره الى ان ناقله عملاقه مخصصه لازاله
النفط ابحرت من الصين في طريقها الى اليمن
ناقله النفط اليمنيه صافر تهديد بيئي منذ
عام 2015
توقفت بالقرب من ميناء الحديده
تحمل مئات الاطنان من النفط الخام وان
ترسب فسيؤدي الى كارثه بيئيه هائله لتصبح
خامسه اكبر تسرب لخزان نفطي في التاريخ
الان وبعد ثمانيه اعوام الامم المتحده
ستبدا عمليه انقاذ ناقله صافر
عمليه تفريغ الناقله ستستغرق من اسبوع الى
شهر بناء على نوعيه النفط ومدى سهوله ضخه
هدف الامم المتحده الاول هو نقل النفط من
ناقله سافر الى السفينه نوتيكا وبعد ذلك
سيتم قطر ناقله الفارغه في عمليه تقدر
كلفتها ب 148 مليون دولار
العمليه لها مخاطر الخبراء ما زالوا بح
اجه لتحديد ما اذا كان هناك اكسجين داخل
خزانه النفط ما قد يؤدي الى انفجار في حال
تعرضها لشراره ما
فاصل قصير نتابع بعده ملفات الخامسه من
قناه العربيه
اهلا بكم نفذت السلطات المصريه اليوم حكم
الاعدام بحق قتل الطالبه نيره اشرف وذلك
بعد رفض الطعن المقدم منه وكان قاتل طالبه
نيره اشرف دينا في محكمه الجنايات بارتكاب
جريمته عمدا مع سبق الاصرار حيث بيت النيه
وعقد العزم على قتلها وتتبعها حتى قام
بالجريمه امام جامعه المنصوره
ومن امام جامعه المنصوره ينضم الينا
الزميل احمد عثمان مراسل العربيه مرحبا بك
احمد يعني انقل لنا الاجواء هذا حكم نهائي
سيطبق حكم الاعدام ما هي ردود الفعل لدى
الاسرتين ولدى بالطبع زملاء نيره نفذ
الحكم
نعم بالفعل لرشا نفذ الحكم صباح اليوم
ويعني هناك لا يوجد حديث في الشارع المصري
او على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي غير تنفيذ
هذا الحكم الذي اتى بعد اقل من عام من
الجريمه التي وقعت احدثها امام هذه
البوابه لو استطيع انقل لك من خلال
الكاميرا يعني هذه هذا كان موقع الجريمه
ايضا يعني هذا المكان ايضا اختلف فيه
تجسيد جرافيتي
للمجني عليها نيره اشرف من قبل زملائها
لهذه الجريمه البشعه التي هزت الشارع
المصري منذ عام تقريبا في العشرين من
يونيو الماضي وربما كانت المحاكمه من اسرع
المحاكمات حتى فتره النقد لم تكن طويله
كما تخيل البعض جميع المحاولات التي حاولت
ان يكون هناك ثغرات في هذه القضيه القضيه
كانت محسومه قانونا لا يوجد فيها اي ثغرات
كما ذكرت رشا هي عمليه قتل حتى فكره مع
سبق الاصرار والترانسد حتى فكره ان يكون
كان هناك محاوله من دفاع الجاني الراحم
بان يكون هناك لديه اضطراب نفسي او خلل
ادى الارتكابه لهذه الجريمه المحكمه لم
تتقبله عوده لسؤالك رشا المتعلق بردود
الافعال هناك بالتاكيد فرحه كبيره جدا
لاسره المجني عليها الراحله هم في مدينه
المحله الاسرتين من مدينه المحله يعني هم
هم كانوا منتسبين الى جماعه المنصوره ولكن
الاسرتين من مدينه المحله فيما يتعلق
باسره المجني عليها الراحله فكان هناك
تصريحات للوالد الذي اكد بانه يشعر اخيرا
بالقصاص بعد عام من رحيل ابنته بعد تنفيذ
الحكم هو الان يشعر بالراحه النفسيه بعد
ان يعني حققت العداله مجراها لم يكن هناك
يعني تصريحات من اسره الجاني هناك
بالتاكيد حاله من يعني
الاستغراب من سرعه التنفيذ يعني لم يكن
هناك يتخيل ربما بان يكون التنفيذ مفاجئا
على ذكر ان المحاكم لا تخطر وسائل الاعلام
بموعد التنفيذ ولكن فورا رفض النقد من حق
الاخطار للمحاكم بالتنفيذ ومن ثم كان
المشهد اليوم صباح اليوم حينما تم ابلاغ
اسره الجاني لاستلام جسمانه بعد تنفيذ حكم
الاعدام عليه استلامه من مستشفى المنصوره
الدولي حيث كانت هناك بعض المشاهد التي تم
تداولها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لخروج سياره الاسعاف نقطه اخيره بان هناك
يعني نوع من الترحيب الكبير في الشارع في
المنصوره على اختلاف ما كان عليه من
انقسام حاد ايام من وقعت الجريمه ما بين
مجموعه تحقق مع الجاني في هذا الوقت نعم
زميلي احمد عثمان مراسل العربيه من امام
جامعه المنصوره بمصر شكرا لك احمد
فشل البرلمان اللبناني في انتخاب رئيس
الجمهوريه للمره الثانيه عشره وخلال جلسه
اليوم حصل المرشح جهه اعزور على 59 صوتا
مقابل 51 صوتا لسليمان فرجيه بينما توزعت
الاصوات المتبقيه ما بين الورقه البيضاء
واسماء اخرى وفقد البرلمان اللبنانيه
النصابه لعقد جلسه ثانيه لانتخاب رئيس
الجمهوريه بعد ان حضر الجلسه الاولى كل
الاعضاء البالغه عددهم 128 عضوا
يحضر خبراء اجتماعيون ونفسيون ممن يصفونه
بالخطر الكبير الذي يهدد المجتمع اللبناني
مع تكشف لارقام مرتفعه للغايه لحالاتي
الانتحار مؤخرا
وضع معيشي صعب وتحديات اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
تبدو حلولها صعبه التحقيق هذا الحال دفع
الياس للتسلل الى نفوس بعض اللبنانيين
خلال الاشهر ثلاثه الاولى من العام الحالي
وثقت احصاءات رسميه 36 حاله انتحار فيما
سجلت احصاءات اخرى 50 حاله انتحارا خلال
اربعه اشهر
من قدام عيوني
انه انا برتاح رب العالمين يمكن تولى
امرهم المعالجه النفسيه في جمعيه امبريس
تقول انه في العام الماضي سجلت
138 حاله انتحار فيما سجل منذ بدايه هذا
العام 38 حاله لافته الى ان هذه الارقام
قد لا تكون دقيقه لان الكثير من حالات
الانتحار لا يعلن عنه الانتحار لمساله
كتير معقده ما لها رابط واحد هي نتيجه
تراكمات عديده بتصير اكيد اكيد
مساله الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه اللي صارت
بلبنان اثرت على الاشخاص اللي عندهم مرض
نفسي ولكن ما في يقول انه هي الرابط
الوحيد يشهد لبنان منذ عام 2019 ازمه
اقتصاديه وماليه صنفها البنك الدولي بين
الازمات الثلاث الاسوا في العالم منذ
منتصف القرن التاسع عشر
وتؤثر هذه الازمه بشده على الاوضاع
الاجتماعيه للبنانيين وتعرقل حصولهم على
الخدمات الاساسيه كما تتسبب بتدهور
الاوضاع الانسانيه نور الحصن العربيه
حصلت اولى رحلات حجاج سودان الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي وعلى متنها 245 حجا وحجا قادمين
من ميناء سواكن ومن المتوقع وصول سفينه
اخرى غدا الخميس تحمل 1900 حجم من السودان
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في اخبار الحاجه حيث يستعد 30 الف
حاجه افغانيه بينهم 8000 سيده للتوجه الى
السعوديه
امين الله عادل وزاهد عادل زوجاني ينيويان
الحج هذا العام يخرجان الى السوق لاقتناء
كل ما يحتاجانه في رحله الحج من حقائب
وملابس الاحرام وغيرها وعند الوداع يجتمع
الاقرباء والاصدقاء في منزلهما ثم يذهبان
الى مجمع الحجاج في كابول لينتظر الرحيل
كنت انتظر هذه الفرصه وانا اشعر بالغ
السعاده لانني اذهب مع اسرتي
وسنقوم باداء الحج سويا في هذه السنه
فاسال الله ان يتقبل منا ومن جميع هؤلاء
حجهم ويجعله حجا مبرورا
هنا وفي هذا المجمع ينتظران مع غيرهما من
الحجاج الذين يتم حشدهم من المقاطعات
الافغانيه الاخرى ان رحله الحج المباركه
تبدا منذ الخروج من المنزل كما تقول
الحاجه زاهده
مدير خشونه انا مسروره ومحظوظه جدا بان
اتاحت لي فرصه السفر الى الحج فثواب حج
بيت الله عظيم والصلاه فيه تعادل الاف
الصلوات في غيره
من هنا ومن مجمع الحجاج في كابول يتم نقل
الحجاج في هذه الحافلات الى المطار الدولي
بيكابول ليبداوا رحلتهم المباركه بعد
اجراءات في المطار عبر طائرات الكامير
الافغانيه الى الاراضي المقدسه عبد النادر
العربيه كابول
وتمهيدا لموسم حجم مليونية شهدت مكه
المكرمه تغييرات خلال الاعوام الماضيه
تتعلق بجوده الحياه وانسنت المدينه لتلبيه
احتياجات الحجاج الزميل نواف عزيز يطلعنا
على واقع هذا البرنامج الجديد في مكه
المكرمه
مكه المكرمه اليوم ليست كما كانت عليه قبل
عام 2019 عندما اطلق برنامج خدمه ضيوف
الرحمن ضمن اطار الرؤيه اينما
ذهبت في العاصمه المقدسه ستلاحظ التغيرات
التي احدثها البرنامج
مسطحات خضراء وممرات مشاه ومحطات للحافلات
واحياء مطوره مدعومه باماكن تسوق وترفيه
تلبي احتياجات الحجاج قبل بدء مناسك الحج
وبعدها
من اكل من مطاعم من حتى الاسواق الاوتيلات
في فرق كبير بالنسبه للاكل للمواصلات
للخدمه هذا شارع المسيال المرتبط بساحات
المسجد الحرام انتهت اعمال التطوير فيه
قبل ايام مع استمرار الاعمال التطويليه في
الشوارع المحاذيه له والمخصصه للمشاه
والتي تشمل التحسينات فيها استبدال
الارضيات وزراعه الاشجار وتشغيل الانارات
الذكيه مع تفعيل خدمات الاتصالات كثره
الناس ومع ذلك ما بيشتكون والامور ماشطه
طبيعيه الاسواق ما شاء الله يعني نساء كان
النساء معنا السنه هذه
الشغلات جديده كانت يعني كتير كتير
مبسوطين في الوقت الذي تستمر فيه اعمال
تحسين المشهد الحضاري وتتسارع اعمال بناء
المشاريع الضخمه في مكه المكرمه يعمل
برنامج خدمه ضيوف الرحمن على تهيئه مواقع
التاريخ الاسلامي بشكل يضمن اثراء التجربه
الدينيه والثقافيه
لزوار مكه من مكه المكرمه نواف عزيز
العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات